today's new member of the day is Michael
honey Chuck before I get into this very
very big story that is an unfortunate
story but an important one I want to
thank Michael for being a member were
mostly funded by members some members
have been with us for a really long time
including Ron Lindsey who's going on
five years of david pakman show
membership doesn't need you don't need
to spend 200 bucks or 150 or a hundred
to move the needle just getting a $6 a
month membership is awesome and if that
sounds high use the coupon code this is
20 20 it'll save you 40% bringing down
that monthly membership to just over $3
a month if you value what we do if
you've been here for a while it'll feel
good trust me it'll feel good to be
supporting us WW join pakman.com Michael
honey Chuck Ron Lindsay thanks to both
of you okay I've been telling you about
the serious problems of the women's
March at this point for years and when I
do the story today that I'm doing this
is not an i-told-you-so story okay this
is a story about it getting beyond even
plausible deniability that the
leadership of the women's March must go
that the leadership of the women's March
does not represent the best of
progressivism and it is simply not a
movement that I as a principled
progressive can get behind I'll remind
you back when the women's March first
formed after Donald Trump's election I
praised many of the goals but after
going to one of the events in the Boston
area I questioned the execution I
questioned the identity politics focus
of the March that I personally attended
I wasn't sure what it was going to be
able to achieve based on the way that it
was structured and focused and over time
we learned about the horrible
anti-semitic and homophobic ties of some
of the leaders this includes Linda
Sarsour Tameka Mallory Bob bland and we
more recently heard that the co-founder
of the March Theresa shook actually said
this has to end these leaders need to
step down and we need other people and
she cited the
connections to known Nation of Islam
anti-semite Louis Farrakhan one of the
most toxic players in politics for the
last many decades in the United States
the praise by Linda Sarsour of the
radical group Muslim Brotherhood is
extraordinarily disturbing and something
that does not fit with progressive
values in any way and Teresa shook
called that out and I told you about
that and I praised her for demanding new
leadership most recently and we didn't
even get a chance to cover this because
it was over our break I believe a
women's March was actually cancelled now
some reports say it was cancelled
because it was going to be all white
people that were planning to go and that
didn't look too good
other reports are that it was merely
logistical reasons why the March was
canceled uh this now gets us to
yesterday okay what I have for you today
is video of two of the women's March
leaders Tameka Mallory and Bob bland and
by the way Bob Linde it sounds like a 60
year old balding accountant but it's not
Bob bland is actually is a woman it's a
pseudonym for a woman whose legal name
is Mary Lynn of Folger folder I believe
it's pronounced okay they appeared on
the view they were asked very specific
questions about their associations a to
Louis Farrakhan to these homophobic and
anti-semitic individuals and movements
including questions from John McCain's
daughter Megan McCain and this has only
furthered my conviction that this is a
toxic group of people that the left
should not have anything to do with
let's get into clip number one there has
been some controversy surrounding the
the women's March organization and and
Tameka you came under some fire for your
relationship with Louis Farrakhan and
the Nation of Islam
now he's known for being anti-semitic
for being homophobic but you do attend
his events and you posted I believe a
photo together calling him the goat
which means the greatest of all time and
you are running an organization that
says it fights biggest bigotry do you
understand why your association with him
is quite problematic okay so
that's the question the the right answer
here is I do understand why it's
problematic even though I've identified
some things that Louis Farrakhan has
done that I think are good it is not
okay to associate with him we are a
movement that believes in ABCD he
clearly does not and therefore we need
to have allies who share all of our
values or at least you know all of our
values maybe maybe a little bit much
you're never going to find anyone who
agrees on everything but who at least
don't hold views so antithetical to what
our movement claims to promote something
like that would have been the right
answer you were praising and associating
with people who espouse the opposite of
the values you claim to espouse in the
March the answer she gives is completely
off the rails I think it's important to
put the my attendance my presence at
saviours day which is the highest holy
day for the Nation of Islam in proper
context you know as a leader as a black
leader in a country that is still
dealing with some very serious
unresolved issues as it relates to the
black experience in this country I go
into a lot of difficult spaces I wrote a
piece immediately following the
beginning of this controversy talking
about
wherever my people are that's where I
must also be so I also go into prisons
where there are people who have been
convicted of heinous acts and I am
trying to help people to move from
wherever they are today and build that
unity to bring them to a place where we
live in a more fair and equitable
society and I think that that work is
not easy for everyone to understand but
it's certainly work that I'm committed
to and everywhere that I go is difficult
the women's march was very difficult
this is such a laughable answer that
it's hard to know where to start she
does number one she does a pivot to
talking about how she goes to a lot of
difficult places to do activism and that
people are just gonna have to understand
that that's that's something she does
for the greater good she says I also go
to prisons to help out and people there
have done some bad things as well that's
a complete red herring that's a death a
joke that's not an argument and then she
also says we'll hold on a second I
went to an event of the Nation of Islam
so basically what she's saying is you
have to ignore everything that the
Nation of Islam and Farrakhan stand for
because she just went to an event
because some of her people were there
this is like saying listen Christmas is
an important day for Christians so you
have to ignore what the Westboro Baptist
Church stands for God hates [ __ ] and all
that stuff I was there because Christmas
is important and they're a Christian
Church and I'm a Christian period and
anything else would be inappropriate to
bring up as a criticism total joke and
she should be embarrassed then and it's
about to get much better in comes Meghan
McCain and you'll notice that after
Meghan McCain makes a number of proven
allegations here the other host asked
Tamika Mallory whether those are
accurate allegations which is a great
thing like let's just get an answer here
do you accept that this is what's been
said do you denounce what's been said
and Tameka Mallory just very pompously
points to Bob bland and says you answer
and avoids having to give a yes or no on
that you just interject really quickly I
would never be comfortable supporting
someone who called
I'm not anti-semite an anti term it-it's
the wicked Jews the false Jews that are
promoting lesbianism homosexuality
actually spoke with the journalist from
tablet magazine who released an
investigation report on your
organization and in part they alleged
that there is a lot of anti-semitism
surrounding this March specifically the
report alleged that you Tamika and
co-founder Carmen Perez asserted that
quote Jewish people had a history of
exploiting black people and were proven
to be leaders of the American slave
trade now a lot of people might a lot of
people include me in this think that
you're using your organization as
anti-semitism masked and activism and
that you're using identity politics to
shield yourself from critiques we're
talking about all women being invited to
that March I'm pro-life we were not
invited we were not allowed at that
March right there I'm a conservative
woman I also represent you're talking
about women to be talking about all
women including Jewish women as well and
conservative women
[Applause]
well first of all those allegations are
not true that is not how that meeting
happened and the women's March said the
German equity was lying the the people
that the journalist spoke to did not
tell the truth just completely off the
rails Tameka Mallory just refusing to
answer Bob LAN saying the information
about that meeting is untrue Megan
McCain listed a whole litany of
statements and claims and the responses
that meeting didn't go that way as if
the issue here is one meeting and then
lastly and this is just difficult to
watch I mean it really is because it's
so embarrassing Tameka Mallory plays coy
with whether she denounces this stuff or
not and good for them for going back and
trying to get a straight answer about
this I don't speak for Jewish people but
I think I'm just confused these are
marks are I mean that goes on death to
Israel over and over again we did not
make those you can't you're associating
with a man what how likely what I will
say to you is that I don't agree with
many of Minister Farrakhan statements
specifically about Jewish people as I
said I don't agree with many of Minister
Farrakhan statement you condemn that me
I don't agree with these statements at
the end of the day he won't condemn it
no no no to be very clear it's not my
language it's not the way that I speak
this is this playing coy that Richard
Spencer did with me on this show and
I'll play a clip for you in a moment do
you condemn the language well there are
many ideas he has that are not my ideas
okay well do you condemn the statements
about Jewish people he says many things
I don't agree with what's so difficult
about just saying hey you know what I do
condemn it I do condemn it period and
this is the same tactic that white
nationalists Richard Spencer tried
playing with me when I interviewed him a
couple years ago check it out I mean
it's almost the exact same game I heard
that you'd will you denounce Adolf
Hitler I heard you don't denounce Adolf
Hitler when asked about that Adolf
National Socialism was it was a it was a
disaster the 20th century was a pretty
much a disaster yeah but do you
denounce the admin of Adolf Hitler I'm
not gonna get I'm not gonna get I'm not
gonna play this game oh it's not a game
throw out historical figures and I
denounce them I mean do you denounce
Stalin do you announce Pol Pot I mean
look yeah the the National Socialist
Germany it's rings a bell right the
movement was bad they made mistakes but
do you denounce Farrakhan in a
statements do you denounce Hitler Tameka
Mallory well they said some things that
are that are not things I would say
Spencer well the movement was a disaster
for National Socialism it's not that
difficult to denounce this stuff give me
a break and the bottom line here is this
is not about litmus tests or about
dividing the left and I told you
yesterday and you pointed this out as
well Pat when we look at tulsi gabbard
we don't necessarily see progressivism
in her foreign policy but that doesn't
mean it's a bad thing that it's another
candidate who supports single-payer
health care for example or even some of
her economic views may not be what we
agree with but maybe others are when I
look at the women's March leadership I
simply don't see individuals that I can
support and be proud of in terms of a
progressive movement period and
ultimately Pat people have to decide for
themselves what they're comfortable with
I'm not comfortable with this yeah and
the women's March was largely successful
especially the first one half a million
to a million people turned out in
Washington DC and then millions more
across the country but I think it's
damaged beyond repair at this point even
if they do change around the leadership
you're not going to get beyond that I
think it's time to wrap it up and call
it a day I tend to agree and sadly
because the activism that has been
catalyzed by the current president and
his administration is something we don't
want to squander but I think that it is
beyond repair at this point send me your
thoughts i'm on instagram at david
pakman the show is on instagram at david
pakman show I'll be taking questions
there this week about this and any other
topics